so you see this impermanence but you
also want to be creative and leave
behind something that is very impactful
is that shots of awe yeah very much so
so when I when I discovered the Ernest
Becker book it it kind of gave voice to
the sensation I was feeling and a little
pop-culture reference about that book
Woody Allen in the movie Annie Hall it's
a book that he buys for her in the
bookstore the denial of death and he's
like this is the book will explain why
I'm so neurotic and terrified the the
universe is meaningless and so on and so
forth I believe in that same documentary
that I mentioned where Sheldon Solomon
speaks the the opening line is this idea
that we have emerged from nothing we
have a name we have consciousness of
self we have deep inner feeling we have
this excruciating inner yearning for
life and self-expression
and yet with all this yet to die all
right
human beings are in quite the
predicament we have the mental capacity
to ponder the infinite yet were housed
in heart pumping breath gasping decaying
body so we're gods and worms and so
essentially he he establishes the human
condition and then he maps the ways in
which we have dealt with the fire in the
belly and there's three historical ways
that we have placated death and put it
out of our minds the first one of course
is religion could have happened before
religion right so religion was the first
antidote to the mortal coil you know if
you serve God you would go to heaven you
would experience salvation you you know
like follow these rules and you will
live forever in the kingdom of God I
mean it works you know and the problem
of course is that religion then gets
corrupted by humans and we use religion
to justify horrific acts against one
another and it's my religion against
your religion and these are
immortality' projects and we fight to
the death for our immortality projects
and of course you know with the
Scientific Revolution and increasingly
secular outlooks religion might be a
pleasant ritual and certainly Gothic
cathedrals and temples and synagogues
can be beautiful architectural
masterpieces that are amage as to the
transcendent but for those of us that
don't aren't convinced that following
the scripture will make us live forever
we need something else to absolve us of
our terror and so the second way in
which we placate mortality is with the
romantic solution to the problem of
death and the romantic solution to the
problem of death of course you guys are
well familiar with I mean that's like
Western civilization and Shakespeare you
know she's like the wind she's my
salvation she is the Sun it's Romeo and
Juliet it's the deification of the other
it's to find somebody that you can
worship that you can elevate to godhood
and that by rubbing up against this
sacred being you will yourself be saved
as what gets reinforced by the movies
and by the pop songs and by the poetry
and it's beautiful to turn a human being
into a god or a goddess I mean in many
ways we are gods and goddesses we just
happen to be gods and goddesses that die
but we are gods and goddesses
nonetheless and so I think that again
the romantic solution is probably death
solves that problem temporarily because
you know it's like it's like that Jewish
mystic Martin Buber talks about ivao
relationships it's like when you truly
encounter another being you truly see
another person as a cosmic being you
elevate them to this position of godhood
you temporarily enter an altered state
of consciousness and which time doesn't
exist I mean to be in love is to be
outside of time
we didn't even achieve that with someone
we don't know by just looking at their
eyes and staying silent for 15 30
seconds potentially yes we glimpsed the
infinite in the eyes of another no doubt
and a guy called Alan Harrington and his
book the immortal list says during these
moments we if you if you think of life
as like this people mover
like those airport people movers and you
know that we're all patiently doing our
thing and living our dramas but the
people whoever keeps going like towards
the ravine that is the end that is the
death of his mitigation of all there is
he says that when we're in love the
altered state of consciousness that is
occasioned by romantic rapture and
Rhapsody takes us out of the people
mover so now we get to co-mingle with
one another as gods outside of time now
I imagine anybody who's ever been in
love ever anybody who's ever lost
themselves in a beautiful song knows
this feeling very well we are absolved
from ourselves in the Rhapsody of love
the problem is it's a transitory
experience it occurs outside of time but
it's still bounded by time when both
ends I know that sounds like a
contradiction that's what seems to
happen it's like well I was outside of
time for three months with this person
now yeah that's life and and and then
what happens he says is that no
relationship can bear the burden of
godhood because the pressure of wanting
to be saved by a finite being puts a lot
of pressure our gods and goddesses
eventually reveal their clay feet right
and that is such a moment of despair and
or disappointment and it's [ __ ] up
because it's it comes with all kinds of
guilt as well like how could you be
disappointed in the one that you love
because they couldn't be who you needed
them to be it's like that Radiohead
lyric that says I wish I could be who
you wanted you know because it's a lot
of pressure in the honeymoon phase and
the honeymoon phase ends and
biochemically we can't sustain these
states as long as we want them to and so
finally he says that there's the third
solution to the problem of death is the
creative solution and the creative
solution to the problem of death might
be called the human Enterprise it's what
we do with that anxiety it's how we
direct that anxiety towards overcoming
limitations overcoming obstacles
transcending ourselves building building
marvelous jetliners and cathedrals and
wireless communication technologies and
making transcendent arts and making
films and creating virtual reality
experiences and concocting places like
Burning Man where we
actualize the human imagination I mean
the creative solution to the problem of
death in many ways is the transcendence
of the problem of death because by many
accounts we have become a geological
force in nature right like if you look
at the topography of any modern city is
something David Deutsch talks about in
the beginning of infinity if you look at
the topography of any modern city like
Manhattan or San Francisco that physical
geography is it's a biography that is
shaped more by mind and economics and
intentionality and culture than by
geology so the creative solution of the
problem of death is that our mind and
our collective efforts have now trumped
geology as a force in nature so that's
like our transcendence of mortality in a
way it's still symbolic ultimately
because everybody still dies but maybe
not for long there's a lot of
billionaires in Silicon Valley working
right now to overcome death by
reprogramming our genetics which by the
way will be the most exciting thing ever
once it spreads to all of us hope was at
first right only accessible by a few
people say but regardless shout-outs
aubrey de grey but ultimately Becker
says that that probably the creative
solution to the problem of death even if
it's purely symbolic even if it's purely
metaphorical even if it's just that you
wrote an amazing poem and that you kind
of you know hurled yourself into the
abyss and realize that it's a featherbed
to quote McKenna like there is a note
that can be like the noble act the
creative act and that allows you to sort
of transcend your death symbolically and
he says it's probably the the healthiest
response to one conundrum to live a life
full of meaning and full of purpose
seems to be the greatest antidote
against this despair that currently
exists